gefahr nach corona lockerungen in hessen
und niedersachsen gibt es neue gruppen
infektionen thüringen dagegen will die
beschränkungen aufheben nahverkehr auf
zwei rädern in corona zeiten fordern
radfahrer mehr platz in den städten und
das ende des ramadan ohne große feiern
wegen corona begrenzen viele islamische
länder das zuckerfest
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg samstag der 23
guten abend und willkommen zu den heute
nachrichten können und sollen die korona
beschränkungen weiter gelockert werden
ein blick nach hessen zeigt wie groß das
risiko ist dort haben sich bei einem
gottesdienst mindestens 40 menschen
infiziert das andere signal kommt aus
thüringen als erstes bundesland will
ministerpräsident ramelow dort die
generellen corona auflagen aufheben
ab juni soll es keine landesweiten
kontakt und abstands beschränkungen mehr
geben über das pro und contra an seinem
stand es hat sich verändert das
alltagsleben in deutschland vorsichtig
verändert in richtung normalität
mehr draußen mehr zusammen mehr ist
wieder möglich
keine beschränkungen in thüringen könnte
das für einige bald realität werden
der ministerpräsident will in seinem
bundesland schon anfang juni das ende
von generellen regeln mindestabstand und
mundschutz nur noch freiwillig so sein
plan und nur noch da wo es zu viele
infizierte gibt
ich möchte dem kabinett vorschlagen dass
wir von dem allgemeinen verordnungs
system in ein lokales geschehen
übergehen also umsteigen wir haben in
der hälfte aller landkreise eine
infektionsrate von 0
und das hat drei wochen am stück der
wunsch nach mehr lockerungen nach mehr
leichtigkeit ist groß überall
doch es gibt weiter auch die schlechten
nachrichten mehr als 40 menschen haben
sich hier in frankfurt am main mit
corona infiziert beim gottesdienst
anders als in restaurants müssen die
besucher weder name noch adresse
dalassen infektionsketten deshalb extrem
schwer zu verfolgen
ausbrüche in den letzten tagen zeigen
auch dass es jedes jeden tag wieder
losgehen kann und wir immer schnell und
gut reagieren müssen dass es uns bisher
sehr gut gelungen das muss uns auch in
der zukunft gelingen insofern dürfen wir
das heft des handelns nicht aus der hand
geben wohl auch deshalb wirbt die
kanzlerin erneut um geduld und um
verständnis
dieses virus ist eine zumutung für
unsere demokratie
und deshalb machen wir es uns natürlich
mit den beschränkungen von grundrechten
nicht einfach deshalb sollen sie so kurz
wie möglich sein
aber sie waren notwendig auch das
deutsche staatsoberhaupt meldet sich
heute zu wort am tag des grundgesetzes
die verfassung werde diese pandemie
überdauern ohne schaden zu nehmen
schreibt der bundespräsident allen
aufrufen zum trotz offenbar nehmen
manche die ansteckungsgefahr nicht mehr
so ernst oder vergessen sie einfach
welche gravierenden folgen das haben
kann zeigt das beispiel eines
restaurants in niedersachsen dort haben
sich an einem abend offenbar mehrere
menschen mit dem corona virus infiziert
christina eglseder und elisabeth schmidt
kaum eröffnet und schon wieder
geschlossen mindestens zehn gäste und
der wird der alten scheune im landkreis
leer positiv auf corona getestet es ist
der bundesweit erste bekannte fall einer
ansteckung in einem gastronomiebetrieb
seit den lockerungen der gastwirt
versichert sich an die regeln gehalten
zu haben
[Musik]
eine darstellung der der landrat
entschieden widerspricht gäste die an
dem abend vor zwei wochen dabei waren
erzählten den behörden etwas anderes
zeugen berichten uns und das sind
indizien dafür dass die regeln nicht
eingehalten worden sind das dann auch
ohne mund nasenschutz sich ein
mitarbeiter des unternehmens an die
tische gesetzt haben soll und es auch zu
händeschütteln kommen sein soll und auch
umarmung eine veranstaltung mit folgen
möglicherweise für die gesamte branche
die nach neun wochen schließt um endlich
licht am horizont gesehen hatte
weil er einfach ein einzelfall war ein
sehr unglücklicher einzelfall es gibt
wirklich nochmal jetzt auch noch mal so
den appell an alle leute ihr müsst euch
einfach an die hygiene konzepte halten
und dann ist auch keine gefahr für den
gast und auch keine gefahr für den
kasten oder die regeln stellt der
vorfall in leer daher nicht in frage
wohl aber ob sie eingehalten wie sie
kontrolliert werden das vertrauen in
einen risikolosen restaurantbesuch
erschüttert also ich persönlich gehe
noch nicht in restaurants
also das ist mir noch zu unsicher ich
weiß nicht ich warte ich warte den
verlauf ab das ist einfach es geht mal
es zu schnell
ich habe mit der ganzen situation kein
problem also ich gehe gerne essen wieder
wir wollen jetzt auch kaffee trinken
dadurch wird man wieder etwas
aufmerksamer was das ganze geschehen
angeht ein ansteckungsgefahr dass kreise
ziehen könnte da die gäste aus mehreren
bundesländern kamen 106 personen stehen
bereits unter häuslicher quarantäne
niedersachsen die trotz des vorfalls in
seinem lockerungskurs festhalten
vorerst immer wieder gibt es orte an
denen sich besonders viele menschen
infizieren
insgesamt aber bewegt sich die zahl der
täglichen neuinfektionen in deutschland
seit etwa einer woche auf einem
ähnlichen niveau
so kommen im durchschnitt der
vergangenen sieben tage derzeit täglich
640 ansteckungen hinzu stand 18 30 hat
die johns hopkins universität seit
ausbruch der pandemie fast 180.000
infizierte registriert davon gelten mehr
als 159.000 als genesen 8256 menschen
sind in verbindung mit 19 gestorben
spd fraktionschef rolf mützenich will
das geplante verbot von werkverträgen in
der fleischindustrie ausweiten
das hatte die regierung wegen der hohen
zahl von corona infektionen in
schlachtbetrieben auf den weg gebracht
mützenich fordert dass der missbrauch
von leih und werk vertreten
werkverträgen entschuldigung in allen
bereichen der wirtschaft verboten wird
für die ausbeutung von arbeitskräften
dürfe es keine toleranz geben
was kann die eu tun um arbeitslosigkeit
und insolvenzen einzudämmen wie kann sie
dem mitgliedstaaten beim wiederaufbau
helfen die besonders stark von der
korona pandemie betroffen sind
deutschland und frankreich hatten dazu
am montag ihr konzept vorgestellt
heute kam der gegenentwurf von
österreich schweden dänemark und den
niederlanden
die selbsternannten sparsamen 4 schlagen
vor den mitgliedstaaten günstige
darlehen zu gewähren die allerdings
zurückgezahlt werden müssen in welcher
gesamte ist noch unklar
der deutsch französische vorschlag um
fast 500 milliarden euro und sie
zuschüsse aus dem eu haushalt vor
die nicht zurückgezahlt werden müssen
wir fragen wir nach bei 100 bürger in
brüssel wie ist der gegenentwurf dieser
vier länder zu bewerten da diese
anderthalb seiten wirken doch eher wie
eine pflichtübung denn wie die
totalblockade die die einen vielleicht
erhofft die am meisten aber doch
befürchtet hatten zwei punkte lassen
darin aufhorchen zum einen sagen die
sparsam 4 erstmals dass auch sie ein
wiederaufbau von haben möchten und
implizit sagen sie auch dass sie
einverstanden wäre wenn die
eu-kommission eben dafür schulden
aufnehmen würde aber und das ist der
zweite punkt sie möchten dass diese
schulden daneben als kredite an die
mitgliedstaaten ausgereicht werden dass
sie also zurückgezahlt werden müssen
der unterschied liegt im detail und vor
allem in der laufzeit die wäre dann
nämlich kürzer und zum beispiel italien
würde dann probleme wieder bekommen mit
seiner kreditwürdigkeit
die eu steht unter druck muss ihre
solidarität in dieser krise beweisen
welches der beiden konzepte die besseren
chancen
die besten chancen hat hier in brüssel
immer ein konzept dass beide positionen
vereinigt alle 27 müssen dabei
wahrscheinlich einem physischen gipfel
im juni dann zustimmen
die eu-kommission wird schon am mittwoch
ihren vorschlag machen
ursula von der leyen die
kommissionspräsidentin hatte im eu
parlament angekündigt dieser vorschlag
werde sowohl kredite als auch
zuwendungen beinhalten und die
stellschraube für eine einigung wird
dann also sein in welchem verhältnis
kredite und zuwendungen dann gemixt
werden also mehr am mittwoch dankeschön
nach brüssel gunnar brücke auch im
verkehr zeigt sich corona deutlich busse
und bahnen sind leer wer kann der meide
derzeit öffentliche verkehrsmittel
die fahrgastzahlen sind nach angaben der
verkehrsministerien um 70 bis 90 prozent
zurückgegangen
viele pendler fahren wieder auto oder
eben fahrrad der radverkehr ist gerade
krisengewinner zum beispiel durch
sogenannte pop up radwege mehr davon
dass forderten heute radler quer durch
die republik romanesco bahn aktionen in
über 40 städten heute umwelt und
fahrradgruppen machen druck statt der
behörden sorgen sie selbst wie hier in
köln für sogenannte pop up radwege sie
fordern temporäre fahrstreifen für
zweiräder zu lasten der autos die korona
krise verändert den nahverkehr haben
deutliche zunahme im radverkehr derzeit
viele menschen meiden den öpnv und
steigen dann auf andere verkehrsmittel
um
wir müssen jetzt aufpassen dass die
menschen nicht alle aufs auto umsteigen
weil dann hätten wir den verkehrskollaps
in den ganzen großstädten
die krise schlug auch in berlin voll
durch bei bus und bahn zwar erholen sich
die fahrgastzahlen langsam bei der bvg
minus 50 prozent im vergleich zum
vorjahr aber immer noch äußerst wenig
anders der autoverkehr mit nur noch
minus zehn bis 15 prozent fast schon
wieder normal
profitiert hat auch hier das rad berlins
verwaltung hat deutschlandweit als
erstes popup radwege eingeführt
von derzeit zehn kilometern länge was
normalerweise jahre dauert ging
ungewohnt schnell parkplätze fielen weg
gewollt im zuge der verkehrswende wir
haben sehr viele leerstehende parkhäuser
in berlin
und wir bieten ja auch alternativen an
durch ausbau des öpnv auch noch weiter
geht durch ausbau des radverkehrs der
städte und gemeindebund allein von pop
up radwegen nicht überzeugt nicht
überall realisierbar greifen sie als
gesamtkonzept auch zu kurz jetzt haben
viele leute angst mit dem bus zu fahren
aber wenn wir die taktung erhöhen dass
weniger leute mit abstand im bus sitzen
ist das genauso wichtig wie das fahrrad
die aktivisten hoffen dagegen dass viele
städte jetzt handeln der fahrrad boom in
folge der korona krise dadurch nicht
wieder abebbt eine meldung aus der
wirtschaft die korona krise trifft einen
der größten autoverleiher
das us-unternehmen herz hat insolvenz
angemeldet auch die marken dollar und
trefft die gehören dazu allerdings soll
der betrieb weitergehen man habe mehr
als eine milliarde dollar an
barbeständen hieß es das unternehmen
solle saniert werden
das internationale geschäft
beispielsweise in europa ist nicht
betroffen
in spanien kehrt das öffentliche leben
langsam wieder zurück die menschen
dürfen wieder freunde treffen sport
treiben shoppen ab montag dann auch in
barcelona und der hauptstadt madrid den
beiden grössten und von corona am
schwersten betroffenen städten
gleichzeitig wachsen die proteste gegen
die regierung und gegen die anti corona
maßnahmen dazu aufgerufen hat spaniens
rechtspopulistische partei vox christel
hass freiheit steht groß auf dem auto
von cristina fernandez die beamtin wirft
der regierung diktatorische tendenzen
vor trete zurück ruft sie eine meinung
die tausende auto und motorradfahrer mit
lautem hupen teilen
wir haben keine freiheit wir haben einen
ausnahmezustand mit bestialischen
einschränkungen denn die regierung mit
sicherheit und der gesundheit der
menschen rechtfertigt
die nationalflagge als zeichen des
protests weil noch ein
versammlungsverbot gilt sind alle
motorisiert gekommen es ist die wut
derer die überwiegend schon immer gegen
die sozialistische regierung waren
ich habe zwei firmen total still stehen
wir haben keine unterstützung nichts an
der spitze des protest kursus der
parteichef der rechtspopulistischen
volkspartei pascal er will den
wachsenden unmut über die korona
maßnahmen der regierung und den
verlängerten alarm zustand für sich
nutzen
im parlament hatte er ministerpräsident
sanchez unfähigkeit vorgeworfen
diese alarmzustand rettet nicht nur
keine leben er zerstört unsere
wirtschaft und lässt sie sterben
er spricht damit vielen spanien aus der
seele
seit tagen schon gibt es in vielen
städten gemeinsames töpfe klappern gegen
die strengen chor ohne regeln so was
spanien wird mehr leiden und sich
langsamer erholen als andere länder
die regierung ist in einer schwierigen
situation denn sie hat im parlament
keine mehrheit
der linke ministerpräsident als buhmann
der verkündete heute dass ab juli wieder
touristen ins land durften
doch diese nachricht erreicht cristina
fernandez nicht sie geht im lauten
hupkonzert unter nach pakistan nach dem
flugzeugabsturz gestern in der
millionenmetropole karachi haben
einsatzkräfte die beiden datenschreiber
geborgen
sie sollen aufschluss über die
unglücksursache geben
der airbus a 320 war kurz vor der
landung in ein wohngebiet gestürzt 97
insassen kamen ums leben zwei passagiere
überlebten
die piloten hatten vor dem absturz von
technischen problemen berichtet heute
geht der ramadan zu ende nach vier
wochen fasten feiern gläubige muslime
dann eigentlich drei tage lang das
zuckerfest
eigentlich denn wegen corona sind die
feiern in den meisten ländern entweder
verboten oder stark eingeschränkt auch
in ägypten
uli gack über das ende der fastenzeit
kairo stadt der 1000 minarette alle
moscheen geschlossen der
ansteckungsgefahr durch corona wiegen
imam hassan bietet allein zu hause statt
mit tausenden anderen in normalen zeiten
letzte arten des fastenmonats morgen
beginnt das zuckerfest corona sagt er
macht einsam
wir sind traurig und es wird schlimmer
wenn uns klar dass wir auch morgen am
zuckerfest allein zuhause bieten werden
in den letzten stunden des ramadan sind
basare brechend voll nicht aber dieses
jahr corona hat ägyptens wirtschaft
ruiniert immer tagelöhner und
familienvater findet seit wochen keine
arbeit wie millionen andere auch er
denkt nicht mal an geschenke für das
zuckerfest
es geht ums überleben soll ich nun geld
auftreiben ohne job ich kann mir nichts
leisten wie soll man sich denn da auf
ramadan oder aufs zuckerfest freue
graffiti vertreiben die allgemein
schlechte laune in kairo glaubt muster
vorhanden
man fühle sich wie inhaftiert durch
diese allgemeine ausgangssperre sagt er
landesweit es ist diese depressive
stimmung auf die mustafa und seine
freunde reagieren
sie haben zeit zu malen ihre jobs sind
verloren war immer ein hassan seine
gläubigen zum zuckerfest nicht anders
erreicht sendet er morgen früh gebete
vom balkon und hofft auf nachahmer in
ganz kairo mit roma botschaft zu
beschallen zum fußball da gibt es eine
interessante personalie mario götze der
siegtorschütze im wm-finale von rio
verlässt tatsächlich im sommer borussia
dortmund das hat bvb sportdirektor
michael zorc bestätigt zu welchem verein
gewechselt ist noch nicht bekannt und
gespielt wurde auch in der fußball
bundesliga gibt es an diesem wochenende
ja den zweiten geister spieltag die
zahlen dazu hat jetzt michael spindler
am nachmittag spielte wolfsburg gegen
dortmund 0 2
gladbach verliert sein heimspiel gegen
leverkusen mit
eins zu drei bremen gewinnt beim sc
freiburg 1 0 der erste sieg für werder
seit über vier monaten
der sc paderborn trennt sich von
hoffenheim eins zu eins aktuell läuft
die partie bayern münchen gegen
eintracht frankfurt und morgen gibt es
dann noch drei sonntagsspiele in der
tabelle führt der fc bayern mit einem
punkt vorsprung vor dortmund die
münchner könnten aber im abendspiel den
abstand wieder vergrößern
eine ausführliche zusammenfassung davon
sehen sie im aktuellen sportstudio
leverkusen schiebt sich auf platz drei
vor gladbach fällt auf rang vier zurück
leipzig als fünfter hat morgen die
chance an beiden vorbei zu ziehen
am tabellenende bleibt düsseldorf auf
dem relegationsplatz bremen als
vorletzter kommt aktuell bis auf zwei
punkte an schlusslicht ist weiterhin der
sc paderborn
das wetter bleibt wechselhaft und eher
kühl mit schauern und gewittern aber
auch mit sonne die details hat gleich
katja honnefer christian sievers begrüßt
sie um viertel vor elf im heute journal
machen sie sich noch einen schönen
samstagabend tschüss und bis morgen
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren das hier
ist die wolken spirale des tiefs gudrun
sehr schön zu erkennen tief gut ruhm
brachte regen genau so wie man sich das
von einem tief ja auch verspricht und so
inzwischen über schottland weiter in
richtung skandinavien
nach dem regen gab es kräftige
regenschauer zum teil auch gewitter mit
hagel und mit sturmböen mit solchen
kräftigeren regenschauern und gewittern
haben wir es jetzt auch noch am abend
und in der nacht zu tun
sie ziehen allerdings dann immer weiter
richtung osten aus deutschland raus dann
lockert auf und an der nordseeküste
kommen schon gleich wer die nächsten
regen sparen
die temperaturen sinken in dieser nacht
auf 11 grad auf den ostfriesischen
inseln und bis 5 grad in den
mittelgebirgen oder am alpenrand und
morgen liegen dann die
höchsttemperaturen um 16 grad wärmer
wird es am mittel- und am oberrhein mit
19 bis 21 grad
morgen vormittag kann es an den alpen
noch ein bisschen regnen dann aber setzt
sich doch von besten immer häufiger die
sonne durch über norddeutschland ziehen
dagegen kräftige regenschauer und
gewitter hinweg am vormittag erreichen
die ungefähr düsseldorf hannover und
berlin am nachmittag dann auch nord
hessen thüringen und sachsen und in den
nächsten tagen beschränken sich die
regenschauer auf den osten
schönes wochenende